let's make Filipino sweet spaghetti in  celebration of Filipino American History  Month we're going to make one of my  favorite dishes that my mom used to make  for me growing up Filipino sweet  spaghetti is one of my favorite comfort  Foods this was definitely one of the  staple dishes that any party my mom  would throw for me especially on my  birthday I was always told to eat  noodles because noodles symbolize a long  life what makes sweet spaghetti so  delicious and unique is the  incorporation of banana ketchup called  jufron it's a popular food condiment  made from banana sugar vinegar and other  spices it's sweet and tangy I also love  the sliced hot dog toppings and the  sharp cheddar cheese many use queso de  Bola or eat em cheese but any quick milk  cheese will do this dish is definitely a  crowd pleaser and will have people  coming back for seconds